yeah we're getting a closer look now at
the life of Lindsay shiver the woman
accused of conspiring to kill her
husband with the help of her boyfriend
newly released body camera video shows
an interaction between shiver First
Responders and her mother-in-law months
ahead of her alleged crime
yeah
yeah she's left
the video stems from an incident on
April 30th in Thomasville Georgia 36
year old shiver a former beauty queen
and Auburn University cheerleader is
seen on camera approaching First
Responders she explains she's in a
custody disagreement about her children
yeah okay my in-laws are in the parking
lot right there in the white Lexus yeah
I've tried to call them this is my
attorney on the phone
and have not been able to get a hold of
them but that's what I was calling for
was for y'all to come meet with me
because we're trying to meet up with
your husband right now shiver's husband
is Robert Schreiber a former Auburn
football player she's now accused of
conspiring to kill him with the help of
her boyfriend 28 year old Terence Bethel
and 28 year old farron Newbold Jr they
were arrested last month in the Bahamas
when police found WhatsApp messages that
laid out the murder plot but months
earlier as shiver was in the process of
a divorce body camera video caught her
amidst a custody dispute
with my family
on the way back this morning they were
in Wiggum 20 30 minutes ago
and then I get the message that they're
dropping he's dropping them with his
parents who have no rights okay
so as a witness for me that's why I
called y'all to meet me at his parents
house you call I called
I was the first one to call
I assumed my complaint it was and they
said the white Lexus and then I called
first okay this morning and then I've
been on the phone with the attorney and
trying to dial them
to ask them where the kids were and
where they were meeting them
the responding Thomas County Sheriff's
deputy explains that shiver's
mother-in-law called law enforcement
reporting she'd been following her
around and making threatening remarks so
they called and said that you were
following them
and harassing them and that's why that's
not the truth I was just trying to see
where they were going to meet my kids if
I needed to call you to tell you it was
the gas station or
the house instead shiver said it was she
who called dispatch after a
recommendation from her attorney okay
safety net
for me and my attorney
has sent his attorney a note saying that
they did not need to go to the in-laws
house
I promise this was all well before y'all
were called by them
what time did you call dispatch
I've had a lot of people this morning
now
at 12 38.
okay
that was probably the
that might have been the original call
then I don't know if there's no I mean
there's no crime here so we're not
but where are my kids I don't know
I don't know it must be they got to be
with your husband which is what just
frolicking around and can until
he drops them with them shiver says she
believes her husband has their kids but
he's not answering her calls
thank you thank your husband still has
them
when was he supposed to bring the bring
the kids back to
this morning oh yeah
no one think it's going to fun yeah
where's your husband been staying oh my
house okay it's a lovely situation
so he just isn't home he hasn't come
home yet
okay
I'll try my son who I tried earlier and
had talked to and he told me they were
in Wiggum
but now I'm sure Robert's got him not
answering the phone the sheriff's deputy
explained shiver's in-laws also reached
out to law enforcement saying they
feared for their safety the whole reason
we're here is they said that you were
following them and they
they uh said you're harassing them
and let me read it I'm pretty sure they
said threatening them but if you ain't
talked to him then
or maybe they felt through it and I
don't know the first responder also
makes note of a gun which shiver denies
having they were saying that you were
following them obviously and that
you got a gun which isn't illegal it
doesn't it doesn't matter though and I'm
like what yeah so she mother-in-laws
something is just freaking out
apparently manic but that's the mental
issue all three of the people in the
carrots yeah
they don't need my kids yeah yeah
they're saying the same thing
foreigners shiver's mother-in-law asks
about this alleged weapon
sure about it she said she did officials
explained Schreiber has not broken the
law suggesting her in-laws should head
home that's when her mother-in-law
claims she's a nervous wreck you guys
can go about your business okay if she's
following you you feel like she's
threatening you in any way from moving
forward you can call 9-1-1 again what we
have right now I'm afraid there's
nothing we can do okay
this whole thing's been documented and
recorded so you ain't got to worry about
that
we just don't have nothing we're not
there she is right there foreign
's mother-in-law then describes a
threatening text shiver allegedly sent
to her own mother
Robin
my name or Robert neither one
[Applause]
then she voices concern about going home
making an ominous comment about shiver's
toxic home environment yeah
she also references shiver's mental
state making a comment about suicide
Lindsay was not answering their phone
calls all day today because they thought
she killed herself to be honest
and had taken an overdose to something
three months after this body camera
video was recorded shiver and her two
co-conspirators were arrested in the
Bahamas she's since been released on one
hundred thousand dollars bail her bail
conditions include multiple things an
evening curfew and order to remain at
least 100 feet away from her husband
she's due back in court on October 5th
reporting for long crime Network I'm
Sierra Gillespie